[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour je m'appelle gala et aujourd'hui
je voudrais vous parler de quelque chose
de très important dans ma vie j'ai dix
ans je suis une petite fille normale
comme les autres je suis en cm2 à
l'école espagnole à paris je fais de la
danse classique du flamenco et je joue
de la guitare un jour en voiture avec ma
mère et mon frère gabriel
on a vu un immense panneau sur une
grande tour à paris sur ce panneau y
avait une image d'un petit garçon le
visage en colère les bras croisés où on
pouvait lire un cancer à 7 ans sérieux
sérieux maman mais comment c'est
possible maman et elle m'a répondu c'est
l'injustice de la vie nous avons de la
chance d'être en bonne santé et nous
devons soutenir la médecine pour guérir
tous ses enfants
et puis chaque jour que je prends le bus
je vois des gens par terre sous la pluie
le froid
et puis chaque soir mes parents
reçoivent des courriers d'associations
qui montrent des images insupportables
vous voyez ces enfants décharnés entre
la vie la mort à trois ans deux anti moi
c'est une honte et du plus profond de
mon coeur je ne veux plus voir ça c'est
injuste que certains aient et que
d'autres non depuis toujours je vois
qu'il y à beaucoup d'injustices
c'est pour cela que j'ai créé une
association qui permettent de combattre
la pauvreté est d'aider les enfants
hospitalisés
cette association s'appelle le trèfle
rousse le trêve c'est le bonheur et la
chance pour tout le monde
oui tout le monde est rouge car ça me
fait penser à croix rouge qui vient
toujours en net
et qui soigne ce que je vous demande
c'est de ne pas garder votre argent pour
rien si vous donnez vous aider et donc
vous sauver je ne suis pas l'abbé pierre
nicu le coluche ou soeur emmanuelle
je suis gala et moi gala disant je
préfère sauver dix enfants que personne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
serait manuel a dit quelque chose de
très important pour moi écouter
comprendre pour mieux répondre aux
besoins des plus démunis
et là tout est possible moi désormais
pour mon anniversaire je vais demander à
mes copains ma famille des dons pour mon
association est arrêté avec tous ces
objets qui envahissent ma chambre et qui
ne me rend pas plus heureuse si tout le
monde faisait ça alors le monde irait
beaucoup mieux
la générosité n'a pas d'âge nous devons
tous donner à tous ces enfants heureux
dans leur vie je les invite à donner un
petit peu c'est cela qui donne du sens à
la vie et c'est cela qui donne du sens à
wingles à ma vie et ne veut pas que
c'est impossible
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh